the Joe Rogan experience what else dude
I would never do a sitcom again ever but
I'm so glad I did do it like I learned a
lot it was a great experience
did you see Andy Dick got arrested again
yeah I had a few and Tommy weren't like
buddy cops you wouldn't do that around
shooting people with guns I do a sketch
who cares about TV anymore right like
it's saying anything I don't watch any
TV shows except for cart the South parks
and the you know the cartoons and stuff
but there's not like a sitcom I gave a
[ __ ] about you know they don't really
exist in one eye caught by Mexican Joker
last night it's great yeah I was trying
to catch up because I saw there they
have a new one tonight oh yeah they got
controversy with China for those those
are the guys that still to this day I
look forward to watching every week they
go hard in the paint do you see the
response that traded to China no Jimmy
said I so yeah trade didn't an official
response to China of them and that
that's what yeah I feel explain to
everybody what happened so they had
South Park had an episode that kind of
mimicked are made fun of the mbas
response or the president of the NBA's
response to China that was in the news
recently and it's about how Hollywood
edits their films like Iron Man 3 has a
host 12-minute scene that they added
just for the Chinese release because
they like make things to make China
happy so they can make more money
because there's so many millions of
people in China what did they have it
you know I it was a scene of an Asian
doctor in like I think they were taking
out the thing in his chest and saving
his life or something like that
yeah they added Asians to it and I think
they cut but this happens a lot in
Hollywood I guess they they they edit
for like a Chinese version where they
even add stuff to it and make it more
Chinese happy so that's so Trey Parker
and Matt Stone made this whole episode
about that and of course you know they
got banned from China China scrubbed the
whole internet free of everything
official apology to China from Trey
Parker and Matt Stone like the NBA we
welcome the Chinese
into our homes into our hearts we do
love money more than freedom and
democracy what how do you say X I G I
think G doesn't look just like Winnie
the Pooh at all tune in to our 300th
episode this Wednesday at 10:00 long
live the great Communist Party of China
may this autumns sorghum harvest be
bountiful we good now China oh my god
he's the best he's the best hey are the
best they are the best I love them
they're the best we too love money let's
say that put bullet point up the exact
quote again what does it say we too love
money more than freedom and democracy
she doesn't look just like Winnie the
Pooh at all I like yeah just adding
[Music]
300th episode that's what we welcome the
Chinese censors into our homes and into
our hearts like the NBA well the NBA
thing is a weird one right like the guy
like he's he's like super social justice
warrior II he's always criticizing this
and that when it came to China he's like
huh huh
everything's really good over there yeah
Commissioner Jim yeah What did he say
I don't know what he said necessarily he
definitely soft pedaled yeah he's
flowing over there now to like have a
meeting about it yeah and there's
there's a chance even that I heard that
he might even could even get fired from
this because that's how much money that
NBA as a company is gonna be losing from
China China now what is the big deal
about China they just like basketball or
is it just just a giant mark just so
many people
[Applause]